reddit has banned a page used by Trump  supporters for failing to abide by the  company's content policy reddit says the  pro tunc Trump community has hosted and  promoted rule breaking content  antagonized other communities and the  group's leaders have failed to meet  basic expectations the social media page  says views across the political spectrum  are allowed but all must work within the  policies meantime twitch a video  streaming service owned by Amazon  founder Jeff Bezos has temporarily  banned president Trump's account for  hateful conduct a rebroadcast of Trump's  2015 campaign launch and comments from  his recent Tulsa rally were flagged by  that company twitch says the content has  been removed the Trump campaign is using  the moves to push people directly to  their campaign